حادثه نادره جدا وقعت في الاكوادور وقد
تسممكم فهذه المسنه التي اعلن عن وفاتها
وظلت داخل النعش لخمس ساعات كامله تبين
انها ما زالت على قيد الحياه اثناء
اخراجها من النعش لدفنها فكيف حدث ذلك
بلا صاحبه السته 76 عاما كانت تلهث بحثا
عن الهوى عندما فتح اقاربها النعش وهم
يستعدون لتبديل ملابسها قبل الدفن وقبل ان
يفتحوا سمعوا اصواتا غريبه تصدر من داخل
التابوت العجوز نقلت سريعا مره اخرى الى
العنايه المركزه في المستشفى فيما شكلت
وزاره الصحه نشله للتحقيق في هذه الحادثه
الغريبه الوزاره اوضحت لاحقا ان الطبيب
الذي اعلن عن وفاه بيلا فعل ذلك بعدما
تعرضت العجوز لسكته قلبيه تنفسيه وتوقفت
على اثرها عضله القلب والجهاز التنفسي ولم
تستجب لمحاولات الانعاش ليتسلمها اقاربها
على اساس انها ميته لكنها في الواقع كانت
في غيبوبه